only on CBS this morning we're revealing
details of a major government clamped
down on illegal robocalls the Federal
Trade Commission and law enforcement
plan to file charges against several
companies and individuals CTM consumer
investigative correspondent Anna Werner
is here with exclusive interviews with
two unlikely allies Anna what did they
say
good morning Anthony we spoke with two
FTC commissioners from opposite ends of
the political spectrum they want to
assure people they're working together
to stop the source of so much
frustration for consumers robo calls and
they're calling it operation call it
quits
it's the ringing in your ears everyone
dreads robocalls the government says
number in the tens of billions every
year this is an important message
regarding your current credit card
account joining forces to find solutions
our FTC commissioner rebecca kelly
slaughter a Democrat and fellow
Commissioner Noah Phillips a Republican
there's no disagreement there's no
political difference here
none whatsoever robo calls are not just
an annoyance that every single American
feels several times a day they could be
a real problem for the people who do
pick up the phone and sometimes fall
victim to those kinds of scams the FTC
is announcing a major crackdown on
illegal robocalls including ninety-four
actions targeting operations around the
country they say are responsible for
more than 1 billion calls I think it is
an extremely important issue we feel
pressure externally we feel pressure and
responsibility internally and we want to
rise to it the FTC says companies
targeted in the enforcement actions
we're using robo calls to pitch
everything from bogus credit card
interest rate reduction services to
fraudulent money-making opportunities
and medical alert systems do you think
you're going to be able to fix it though
I mean what they're doing is illegal
much of it comes from overseas how do
you even stop that so today announcing
operation call it quits is part of the
solution to the problem it is not the
hole of the solution it's going to take
engagement from industry it's going to
take technological development it's
going to take engagement from
Zoomers which we at the FTC also try to
do and the hope is for all these
combined efforts we can help push back
our job at the FTC is to enforce the law
that we have and that is the thing that
I think we are very very actively
focused on doing here
experts applaud the joint law
enforcement efforts but say the
dampening effect on illegal robocalls
may only be temporary Alec Squillace is
CEO of the call blocking company you
mail when there's a crackdown or an
enforcement action you see fewer robo
calls from the people who were crackdown
on they usually stop the challenges
they're replaced by someone else who
often does the same scam it often feels
like whack-a-mole for us but when we
whack Amole we are stopping a
substantial number of cases of a number
of unwanted calls and that's that's
important to me among the seven FTC
cases for our new and three our new
settlements the defendants in some of
those cases have already had their
assets frozen others are expected to
potentially pay fines ranging anywhere
from a quarter of a million to two
million dollars but some people think
they should go to jail I do yeah you
think this could would be easier yeah no
I think it's complex I mean you have all
the overseas calls you have these
domestic businesses that they're going
after now they're also trying to go
after the people that supply the
technology make it possible for a lot of
people to do robo calls as well but it
is interesting it is good to see
Democrats and Republicans can agree on
something
they say they are able to everybody just
that just annoys everybody I don't care
who y'all yeah just hearing the rings in
your package I was getting anxiety
started twitching thank you very much